[Musik]
hallo
genau heute gibt ein leckeres
nachgemacht video und zwar auch von mir
aus wunsch hin denn samira ist total
gerne auch braithwaite rot also wenn wir
mal in einer künstlerin stadt sind aus
der waghäusel ohne dort einen subway
laden gibt und samira dabei ist möchte
sie doch immer gerne hin
denn sie ist am liebsten was ist ja das
ist ihr lieblingsfoto und ich hab
gedacht kommen bei mir machen und so
ziert daheim einfach mal nach das heißt
heute gibt's dieses grundrezept für die
fabrik brötchen
wir machen jetzt die variante cheese
oregano und das ist eigentlich um
verliebte variante murat wählen sie auch
immer wann ihre wohnzimmer und ich auch
schmeckt richtig lecker vor allem könnt
ihr diese brote gut vorbereiten und die
elle auch eigentliche mittlerweile schon
und die bude könnte gut vorbereiten
lagern er könnte einfrieren und immer
wieder nach bedarf einfach euer brot
aufholen und euer sandwich gelegen
welches kohl richtig genial und die zu
haben sind auch ganz einfach etwas
wirklich gar kein hexenwerk deswegen
starten wir jetzt gibt es nicht ist
alles aus
daher ist eigentlich super lecker und da
gibt es wege sechs verschiedene boote
und heute gibt es eben die variante
these also parmesan mit oregano die
zubereitung geht super einfach deswegen
starten wir jetzt hier gleich mit den
zutaten für den teig brauch ich 730
gramm mehl einen würfel hefe 100
milliliter lauwarmes wasser einen
esslöffel zuckerrübensirup 300 gramm
butter milch 1 1 1 1 2 teelöffel salz
und 60 gramm butter
ich werde zuerst einmal das unternehmen
die hefe darin auflösen und mit dem
zuckerrübensirup verrühren
[Musik]
die hefe mischung denke ich jetzt auch
plastik für etwa 15 minuten stehen jetzt
die haare schön aufgegangen viel last
bereits die butter schmelzen und gebe
jetzt sondern mal die jeder mischung in
meine küchenmaschine
wir können den tag auch mit den händen
verkneten natürlich aber ich mache immer
gern mit der küchenmaschine war ich dann
die hände frei hat oder ein bisschen
einfacher geht
[Musik]
dann auch die buttermilch
und ich kann nicht einfach bereits
kneten kommt die flüssige butter mit
rein und dann lasse ich ihn zeigt
bezweifelt dass lebensmittel
jetzt ist der tag perfekt ist es ein
schöner weiter und geschmeidiger zeigt
jetzt hätte ich meine arbeitsfläche und
auch ein bisschen die hände
[Musik]
form die ihn so weit es geht zu einer
kugel zusammen und fettet auch die
rührschüssel da kommt derzeit wieder
hinein und ich hätte ihnen ist auch ein
bisschen weg gemacht und was ihn für
etwas 60 minuten aus
der teig ist es wunderschön aufgegangen
jetzt kann ich meine arbeitsfläche in
diesen fetten immer gerne backt rente
weil ich schon auch die backform
gleichheit eintreten werde
jetzt könnt ihr selbst entscheiden wie
groß die fans werden soll
ich werde sie jetzt ab mit 30 zentimeter
lang machen
das heißt ich mache 200 gramm portionen
ihr könnt aber auch zum beispiel nur 150
gramm nehmen oder auch nur 100 falls ihr
dann ein kleines grüppchen haben möchte
[Musik]
denn
habe ich sechs große baguette und kann
ich hier mit der hand das ganze ein
bisschen öffnen
das land wird nämlich formen
jetzt geht ihr auch schon in die länge
[Musik]
wenn ich die backform ein vettel ich
habe hier backbleche basis eignet sich
natürlich hervorragend falls ihr die
nicht ablegt ihr die teiglinge jetzt
einfach auf ein ganz normales backblech
[Musik]
die werden jetzt mit frischhaltefolie
abgedeckt damit sie auf keinen fall auf
trocken und so werde ich sie dann noch
mal eine halbe stunde aufgehen lassen
jetzt bin ich schön aufgegangen und
werde jetzt noch bestreichen und
bestreuen
ich mach s p variante cheese oregano das
ist meine lieblingsfarbe ernte selbst
hier einen esslöffel getrocknet und
oregano und da kommt jetzt noch calasan
dazu etwa 50 gramm wenige ausnahmen
stück dann auch gerne etwas mehr
[Musik]
sauerei kann 45 zimmer verhindern wenn
ich diese ganze jetzt habe ich hier ein
eigelb mit etwa 50 milliliter wasser
verrührt und jetzt werden die teiglinge
damit gestrichen
das dient zum einen dazu dass eben
dieser belag schön hält und zum anderen
dass sie eben schöne farbe bekommen
jetzt nach dem käse kräutermischung
drauf
[Musik]
so kommen wir jetzt in den vorgeheizten
backofen und zwar habe ich den preis auf
200 grad ober unterhitze vor geheilt wo
es sind ganz vorsichtig runter rutscht
denn ich habe ja auch mal ein backblech
umgedreht das heißt anders vorgenommen
das einfach die zwei parkplätze drauf
passen geht es jetzt hierher 15 bis 20
minuten gebacken und damit sie eine
richtig tolle gruppe bekommen stelle ich
noch ein schälchen mit wasser rein
moderne backöfen haben einfach vom
samstag hier geht es aber auch los und
ihr 15 bis 20 minuten
ich werde später allerdings zu machen
müssen dass ich fünf minuten vor ende
der backzeit ein bisschen rausnehmen und
das backblech noch mal nach hinten
schieben damit sie von unten aufbauen
werden weil einfach meine unter hitze
nicht ganz so gut funktioniert jetzt ist
von mir dran die ersten brötchen sind
fertig dürfen nämlich die dich davon
bereits gebacken habt denn bei uns gab's
gestern schon sandwich und liebe
zanirato erzählst jetzt den dieben zu
schauen was dein lieblings sandwiches
mit käse machen wir also wenn ihr jetzt
zuerst mal ein brötchen macht die hälfte
[Musik]
ich find auch weiter gut ich später 1
mit kindern machen jetzt ernst mit dem
backofen warm
23 minuten vorbereiten das heißt wir
geben mit thunfisch und frischkäse in
ein haus voll gefäß und jim courier
wir machen das zusammen
[Musik]
probleme oder auch wenn auch sonst dass
verbraucher gut macht
erst ein trash jetzt nicht getrost otto
christ war macht jetzt darfst du da drin
was drauf streichen
hier sind liegt unsere seite verteilt
noch ein bisschen mit dem löffel und ich
kann schon mal eine kurze hose
zumal jetzt noch ein paar kurzen
schreiben ich so seht ihr hier oder ein
paar dickere zwar nur ein paar dickere
hier drehen meint van lent wird fertig
belegt stopp beim gipfel muss der deckel
drauf sind die politik schon mal fertig
und ihm ist jetzt ganz heiß aus dem
backofen noch mit flüssiger butter
bestreichen
so werden sie auch richtig schön weich
und dann denke ich sie ab und lasse
komplett abhängen
und dann könnt ihr sie ganz frisch oder
am nächsten tag getoastet essen
verstehen
und
ist gut besser als bad boy naja
wenigstens ist er ließ noch mal probiert
aber abreißen einmal abbrechen
na ja nicht unbedingt aber einmal ein
kleiner pieks wie bei sagt der coach
vielleicht noch mittel nach vanille
extras lusebrink öl und wasser an frauen
doch voll witzig verstanden wir graf
waren mit sanierer und murat ort
einkaufen zum abholen rein und hab
gerade ausgesuchten was esse ich denn
jetzt live und dann sagt die verkäuferin
zum orad orad hier gibt es aber kein
zurück
und hier gibt es noch weitere also ich
finde die brötchen die dies obwohl brote
richtig genial wie gesagt ihr könnt auch
verwahren bis zum nächsten tag
ihr könnt aber auch 10 und dann einfach
bei bedarf kürzel den backofen schieben
wir werden unsere ziele gleich noch ein
paar fach belegen auf jeden fall hat uns
das ganz viel spaß gemacht und falls ihr
das rezept nachmachen möchte geht
auffällig blog.de
da steht nämlich noch mal ganz genau und
ich wünsche euch ganz ganz viel spaß und
nachmachen und bis zum nächsten mal auch
lecker machen wer nimmt
[Musik]
b